a penas es abril y la temperatura ya
está aumentando en nueva delhi a
principios de semana estuvo por encima
de los 40 grados en la capital en
algunos lugares el norte el termómetro
de estado de 6 a 10 grados por encima
del promedio
quienes trabajan en oficinas se refugian
bajo techo para otros esa no es una
opción
aunque haya mucho calor hay que trabajar
si no trabajamos no comemos los
asalariados trabajamos a pesar del calor
y
empiezo a trabajar a las 6 y cuando
termino ya pasan de las 12 y está muy
caliente espero el bus bajo un sol que
quema
todos los días me duele la cabeza no
puedo ni explicar el calor que hace
moverme desde mediados de marzo los
reportes se carga máxima de la red
eléctrica han sido rutinarios cerca del
récord que se alcanzó en julio del año
pasado en el pico del verano una
consecuencia de temperaturas más altas
de lo habitual
repunta también la demanda de aire
acondicionado y de refrigeradores cuando
todavía faltan meses para que llegue el
verano se espera que los cortes de
energía sean frecuentes
todos los años es lo mismo sabemos que
hay una escasez de agua que ahora todos
enfrentamos como sabes las olas de calor
son un hoyo en tu bolsillo que cada vez
que tienes que encender el aire
acondicionado y llegan las facturas no
es bueno para nadie
aníbal la red eléctrica apenas alcanza a
manejar la demanda y las familias a
pagar sus cuentas los residentes de
nueva delhi pronostican que las cosas
empeorarán los próximos días